it was Joshua Wong's third day in Berlin
he came to the German capital with a
message for angular Merkel and other
world leaders it's a must for the
Chancellor pay attention to Hong Kong's
protests and showed us a part to Hong
Kong's democratization safeguard Hong
Kong is not only the responsibility of
Hong Kong people but also the
responsibility for world leaders prevent
Hong Kong to face the next Hanuman
Square massacre happened three decades
ago on Monday Wong met German Foreign
Minister Heiko Maas prompting sharp
criticism from Beijing it summoned
Germany's Ambassador accusing Berlin of
interfering in China's affairs what
happened now I unfortunately have to say
will have negative consequences on
bilateral relations and China will have
to react Humboldt University Joshua Wong
packed out the room here to his message
was one of defiance and a strong belief
in the power of the protest movement in
his home city no matter youngster and
elderly all we stand as one with our
determination to fight for better future
Joshua Wong find many supporters in the
German capital I think he did a good job
he did like he didn't act like a hero
instead he just he he is very honest
about it that he is a facilitator and he
let the world knows about the Bardo
person's mood he's very impressive very
brave and he's still very young I find
him particularly admirable because he's
risking his life and freedom with his
activism activism was just killed Joshua
in person
I think it's a huge motivation for
people who are abroad a concordance Ofra
- so be motivated and follow closely to
what is happening in our home city many
here tell us they're concerned about
Joshua Wong and what will happen to him
when he returns to Hong Kong but first
he's heading for the United States where
he hopes to gain more support for Hong
Kong's pro-democracy movement get more
on the story we have team coverage DWS
chief political correspondent Melinda
Crain is in Beijing and correspondent
Matias Bollinger is in Hong Kong for us
Melinda I'll begin with you because
these were an extraordinary reaction
from the Chinese how is the German
government responding to Beijing's harsh
harsh criticism of the long visit the
Foreign Ministry rejected the criticism
saying on Tuesday that it was perfectly
normal procedure for a foreign minister
to meet with members of civil society
and yesterday in her speech to
Parliament we heard a very clear
statement from Chancellor Angela Merkel
saying that she had used her recent
visit last week to Beijing to tell the
government that the German that Germany
views human rights as absolutely
indispensable and she said we still
stand by the principle one country two
systems' on the other hand there is also
a certain degree of caution here in
Berlin the Chancellor's spokesman has
emphasized that she herself did not meet
with Joshua Wong and that meeting with
the Foreign Minister actually took place
on the margins of a private reception by
a German newspaper that in fact is the
host for this visit by Joshua Wong
Melinda Wong also held a press
conference here in Berlin yesterday just
walk us through what he said he said
that he'd like to hear a much stronger
statement from the German government
condemning the police violence in Hong
Kong a condemning abuse of power he also
said he'd like to see the government
stop exports of police equipment to Hong
Kong as
as there is continuing violence against
the protesters and thirdly he said he'd
like to see Germany link trade it's
flourishing trade with China struck more
strongly to human rights concerns
perhaps even in inserting a human rights
clause into trade agreements so three
very very clear messages from him to the
German government Matias why is China so
upset about the wan visit well the
protests are entering the fourth month
now it's been three months two days ago
since the protests have started in China
and the Hong Kong government have found
now no way to calm the situation
protests are going on they're getting
more extreme more violent so this is
something Beijing is extremely nervous
about the other thing is that Beijing
has been trying to control the messages
or how China's affairs what they view as
their internal affairs abroad more
assertively during the last few years
companies have been punished if they
labeled for example Taiwan not as a
province of China and Beijing has been
extremely nervous about foreign leaders
meeting people that they do not want to
have that whose voices they do not want
to have heard so Angela Merkel for
example was meeting the Dalai Lama when
she just came to office in 2005 and
China had reacted to this with some
restrictions on German diplomats and
since then Angela Merkel has not met the
Dalai Lama again so their strategy is to
punish all those who meet with people
the China does not want to be on stage
mattias you know ultimately the message
from Beijing is this implication that
there will be consequences for sino
German ties walk us through what those
consequences might be well it will start
with diplomatic snubs German diplomats
not getting appointments with senior
officials for example are not being
invited to some celebrations some events
that are organized by the Chinese for
in community it can go further it can
harm German businesses in China
companies can be singled out for example
some inspections or some trade
restrictions can be placed the public
can be organized against German
businesses this would however be a
further step of escalation and I do not
think that this would be at the
beginning of a process like this because
at the moment in in this situation where
China is at a trade war with the US they
need Germany and they will probably
resort to some more measured responses
but they want the Germans to feel some
consequences Malinda given that I mean
given that there is a mutually
beneficial relationship and yet we have
these threats here how should Germany
how worried should they be about this
Chinese warning China is an incredibly
important trading partner for Germany
Germany is seeing the economy take a
downturn partly because of tensions
between the US and China which have
reverberating effects for this very
export-driven economy here in Germany
certainly the business community will be
concerned for that reason one major
business newspaper said today that the
foreign ministers move to meet with
Joshua Wong had done maximum damage but
I think Mattias is right in saying the
Chinese themselves don't have much
interest in starting a two-front trade
war so perhaps the the threat will in
fact not be carried out with full
consequences by China Melinda and Matias
thank you so much to both of you for
your reporting